very long history but I've been in the
Sun for about 19 years we have offices
here we have offices in Israel and then
we have offices in India Bangalore and
in Mumbai
with large font you know about 2 and 1/2
billion or the management about 16
partners for 1516 partners focused on
early stage and a little bit of late
stage investments as well both here as
well as as I said in Israel and India
and a little bit in China January in
Gupta Nexus India capital we are focused
exclusively on Indian early stage
generally speaking you know really help
enterpreneurs build great companies
starting from from ground zero
the three partners three senior partners
and a few other people all of our
partners come with entrepreneurial
background the all started companies we
made them successful so I think we
understand the pain a little bit of what
it takes to create companies before that
I started the company and I was running
it for 15 years to get public and the
CEO of a public company and before that
privately held company and before that I
went to Stanford but not the business
school I went to the engineering school
of a PhD from from Stanford in
engineering so I know that campus a
little bit but then I will come back to
you that's right that's right
they don't make too much fun of me here
you know I think I've died as less money
I'm the founder and CEO of g-box we are
an online video advertising startup
based in India as well as here in the US
about half our businesses in India half
here in the US my background is this is
my third company first one was
informatica which went public in 99
second was Selleck West which got
acquired in 2007 so we'll see about the
students so far so far so good
I'm basa Pradhan I'm the CEO of
gritstone Research gritstone builds
technology for equity research we have
an office here in San Mateo and an
office in Mumbai where most of our
engineering and operations what gets
done I've been with this company for
three and a half years I founded the
company with some of my co-founders we
were all at Infosys technologies prior
to this I ran global head and I was
sorry head of global sales and marketing
for three years in a total of eleven
years at Infosys so let me get started
with bhaisaab you you're the numbers guy
right and research guy what do you see
happening in India right now in terms of
impact on the global economic crisis
how's that impacted India how strong is
in Europe in comparison to the US and
maybe if you know if you like north
chime in with China
you know comparisons to China okay now
so out here I guess you don't need a any
further information what's going on here
if you read the papers it's a it's all
about you know job losses in the market
hitting a 12 year low and so on in India
if you if you look at the markets it
they went down more sharply compared to
to the to the index here but actually
it's currently 20% up from its lows if
you I was actually in India week back
and I was at my 20-year reunion at the
business school I went to which is I'm
on the back and you know there was a
cross-section of views obviously all of
us were talking about what's going on in
India and the world and the financial
crisis and the what you could get from
the people in the markets in the capital
markets was that this is bad it's going
to get worse and it's going to be really
long and India is not going to escape
the the brunt of this it is you haven't
seen nothing yet
right and the business guys and there's
several people who either run businesses
or are basing your people in large
business than ever
across what's happening in India they
were a little less pessimistic I
wouldn't call them optimistic but little
less pessimistic because and they felt
that there were a few things that were
going wrong one is that demanding global
markets was drying up because a lot of
the demand that comes in comes from the
developed markets and those the markets
they're doing poorly
so industries like IT services other
export you're oriented industries are
going to do poorly in India anything
that depends on credit like the real
estate market like you know large
infrastructure projects and even you
know manufacturing by and large and a
lot of credit is is goes into
manufacturing they are not going to do
well because credit is very tight and
and anything to do with the capital
markets of course in India as well so so
these were the three things that were
were were negative and we're going to
stay negative or get worse in the future
but on the positive side unlike say
China
India's services and manufacturing
exports as a percentage of GDP is much
smaller than China's and so that the
dependence on the global demand is less
but it is not you know it's not
insignificant of course and there's a
large domestic market in large middle
class which which continues to aspire
for you know better things in life and
they will buy new services new products
and of course if they don't have cash
flow if they don't have jobs that does
impact them so I think you know
unbalanced my view is that a recovery in
India can be expected sooner and then
here growth will be muted but it will it
will still be there for for the period
of time when there is a recession in the
US
so I guess I'll turn to Noreen and
promote the investors perspective you
guys invest in India and I suppose you
have to also again end up traveling to
India and when you're India also within
India two different jurisdictions can
you for the audience Peschel folks here
a lot of people folks who seem like you
know they've been to India or listen or
familiar with but for especially for
people to not understand India as well
or for those know few here who may not
have ever been to India can you map
India for us you know what what are the
jurisdictions that are critical what are
the hot centers of innovation
entrepreneurship in India and also maybe
Church I mean it's our experiences about
when you travel to India how is it
different from traveling here you know
the infrastructure roads hotels the buzz
at the airports you know and the you
know you have to smell anything that you
can talk about for someone who's tribe
who has never been to India you know
who's traveled but not been an investor
or spend a whole lot of time on the
ground in India would love to hear your
thoughts now but you know I go there
every two months in fact I'm headed
there not next week for the following
week you know I think the the
infrastructure obviously is pretty weak
compared let's say to you know what you
see in Europe you see in air it's being
upgraded so you know if you if you go
for example to Bangalore Airport now the
new Bangalore Airport it's just as good
as any of the other airports that you'll
find air but you go outside right all of
a sudden goodbye lack of access and
takes forever to get anywhere because
you know because the access to the
airport and the infrastructure and the
roads are still narrow and small and so
on but you know if you look at the
hotels and all I mean leaving access
aside you know you you see islands of
you know hotels and restaurants and so
on you know that are just as good as
anything you would find here in fact you
know I would say that the service level
in some of those hotels is far far
superior term service levels you'll find
in 5-star hotels here in the US a lot of
that's got to do with you know labor
being cheaper and so services is offered
very nicely
I think you know Airlines you know again
you know very good airlines now some of
them are in turmoil right now as as our
Airlines here so there's some
restructuring going on in the airline's
industry flights are getting cut back
and so on but you know premier airlines
business airlines you know do very well
and and perform very well again the
congestion is you know once you get to
the airport easier to get from the
airport to where you need to go so
that's always a challenge but you know
the hubs you know I mean the technology
hubs you know obviously Bangalore and
then you've got isolate you know other
other hubs you know Mumbai is the
business center and you know a lot of
deals get done there Delhi cool down
specially it sort of an upcoming hub
then you've got Chennai also as an
interesting Hyderabad and pull a you
know very interesting technology centers
you see a lot of companies from here
that are outsourced there so that's by
and large the large cities where you
want to be okay Noreen do you enjoy
traveling to India and you look forward
to it is that a challenge
yeah well you can talk about you know
certain lack of running water in the
bathrooms at airports to the actual UN I
tell it's just a lot of people the buzz
at the airport you know if you want to
see what's happening in India even
though you're standing in a big line
it's so exciting you know people on the
blackberries they're doing deals you
know well so you know anything from the
extremes that you are I think traveling
to India is a bit harder than 9:00 to
New York of 90 Los Angeles and you know
first of all there is no nonstop from
here which always sort of bugs me a
little bit but that's the way it is I
guess I wish I was in New York so I
could take a nonstop to India but I
don't think that really is a issue from
my point of view you know I think like
Primeau said you know we end up
traveling to India quite frequently it
is just the way it is I think outside
once you are in India it's a bigger
problem
I mean can take longer to go from you
know the airport in Bombay to our office
which is Navy's eight miles away then to
fly from Bombay to Delhi but it's a
thousand miles or 800 miles you know so
I think I think you can't have that
confess to bother you at all but I mean
I doesn't bother me even in the least
but should be prepared for it usually
prepared for it and not
plane and be patient let's write the non
impatient your service level phone
series or hotels are absolutely as
promotional fantastic mounting it really
really really bothers bothers me I think
the thing that that is problematic is
the is dub as the pain or company
suffered because of the interest from
real estate is very expensive to start
to rent offices good office is very
expensive they are commuting on those
roads every day wasting two hours at
that time and that's what really bugs me
a lot is that there a lot of
productivity is being wasted because
they are remain everyday we do it once
in a while it's not end of the world
but I so I would say definitely
productivity in India can be lowered
because the infrastructure issues I
think a lot of its the how the culture
local culture deals with it also also
give you kind of a number very
interesting you know Italian analysis of
what goes on in India in different
places and I was in Bombay for about six
weeks a year now back and and you know I
said say how many meetings start on time
just like 85% or 90% meetings in Bombay
start in time and tell you the number is
20% so I think it's sort of you know
buddy the India is very uniform in many
ways but also very different in many
many respects so you're not even a it
just sort of deal with that stuff but to
me the biggest issue is the productivity
how does it impact the productivity of a
common person in India because of poor
infrastructure and I don't think that
really affects innovation or anything
people work around it I wouldn't worry
about that stuff is bad but everyone is
part of being an entrepreneur I have a
part of unity products I guess let me
use that to lead into another discussion
which is more substantive about lack of
ecosystem for entrepreneurship as such
you know we typically you know folks
from Stanford especially people some of
people here would to two guys in a dog
in a garage you know would go out set
something up bootstrap or a little bit
go to their friends family raise a bit
of angel rounds or get mentors service
providers lawyers you know doing free
book for free or deferrals
other advisors to the whole ecosystem as
we understand it how much of that is
really available or set up in India and
it's Bangalore truly you know the
Silicon Valley that
respect I would argue that Bangalore is
not Silicon Valley and the whole India
is Silicon Valley because this ends
innovation in Delhi or Bombay and
different sort of ideas have kind of
concentrated around various thing
Bombay's or the center of innovation in
the consumer products space and media
and financial services and so on then
not clearly you know pure technology so
I would say that that is any Isaiah is
also if there is innovation all across I
don't think it really matters greatly
where you are it might a song but not
really I think the
anyway I like you know what is Pune is a
good place jenna is a good place
Hyderabad is a good place in many
restore any kind of company because a
house impossible it's just too expensive
live in Bonn before anybody and them
neol da over the world you know so I
think that's the kind of things that
that that really I would sort of think
off in terms of what might create the
next sort of a center but it's much more
likely to be the small country is
probably most of you know you can fly
across India in two and a half hours or
something like that up and down maybe
three hours you know so it sound like
that that big a deal
see you know so I I would sort of really
say that you know diets what would you
say you know if you're a entrepreneur
starting up compare that no no starting
up in the valley to someone starting and
especially for you know technology
startup sort of in all business yeah how
is it different and what's available in
India was interesting when we went to
India to look at where to start you know
I talked to a lot of people and I got as
many opinions as you know the number of
people I met and I think they were all
right in different ways it depends if
you're looking for the lowest cost labor
you know something else like go to
climate or don't go to you know Chennai
Bangalore
Bobby and so on if you're looking if
you're outsourcing meaning here is sort
of setting up a call center or some sort
of lower skill level operation those
cities are great so it took me some time
to truly understand what they were
saying and you know we ended up picking
Bangalore as as a you know because our
goes to develop hard core technology and
we felt like the best talent for that
was in Bangalore we also wanted to have
some basic infrastructure that could
help the
running so I picked it you know I don't
know if it was the best choice in the
long run in fact we're thinking as we
grow we may set up a satellite and Pune
or something like that for as we add one
more people so I think you know the
major hubs are generally very good I
think the differences are getting to be
minimal now in terms of infrastructure
expenses for example we found at least
this was say a year and a half ago I
looked at the office prices between
these cities and they were marginal
differences and hiring people was very
difficult in Bangalore easier in other
cities and so on so forth so you kind of
look at the whole picture it also
depends the kind of kind of business you
start trying to start and pick on that
basis it's very hard to say Oh Pune is
the place or Chennai thing is precise to
geographical locations I wouldn't kneel
down you know how easy is it to get the
support services that you have or you
take for granted here you know the
access to advisors mentors yeah I mean I
can speak from Bangalore Bangalore was
was not very difficult and I think it's
traditionally had some of that network
of with its law firm accounting you know
venture capital investors cetera et
cetera so we didn't have a very
difficult time setting up but you know I
don't know you guys might know a little
more about this house you know four or
five cities that we talked about you
know this you know infrastructure is
available services are available you
know service providers attorney so you
could be from an IIT or I am and to love
bug and play sort of you know work and
get get started pretty quickly one thing
I was going to say whether near if you
look at statistics in the u.s. most
company people end up an or start
business within ten miles of their house
that's just a number so I mean you don't
want to approve your family and stuff
like that and just don't really matter
that much in Madison particularly now it
matters more because Silicon Valley is
behind the center of it but make
yourself convenient make it come in for
yourself wanna prove your families don't
you know cause yourself too much pain
you know you have plenty of pain
starting the company
anyway it's not that many wayside my
advice is don't worry about that just
just do it make it clean for yourself
okay yeah okay I guess back to the
investors then and I've heard you know
different version for entrepreneurs
investors but in terms of availability
of early-stage investments investors I
think say that they aren't as many
early-stage opportunities entrepreneurs
say they aren't as many in the capital
it's not as acts and you're accessible
in India for least a sort of is this a
chicken-and-egg I mean how do you get
started in early stage you know what
should come first should investors set
up money and have they for investments
and have some commitment that will drive
innovation and get more people to start
early stage companies and start at the
scratch or is it that you need to show
some success no but companies that you
know the googles and then to be able to
get that illegal I would say that both
sides have certain amount of all I think
one of the people in India come to us
they did it could have good businessman
I would say they're not they don't
really understand what it takes to get a
company funded they keep company funded
I mean we were looking for company that
was scared to now its size is we're not
looking for somebody you know running a
small business that produces cash flow
that's not really the kind of to go to
do nothing but while that is affected is
that they are not enough what I would
call smart changers in India people you
know I mean and when I started a company
in the u.s. I called four people and
said hey guess what I'm planning to do
what do you think and then an hour or
two you know you get decent advice maybe
not perfect like definite not perfect
but you get some advice on hey you know
you should do this or not that or
whatever so I think I think that is
really to me the key is people
entrepreneurs can go to before they come
to us because I mean here we are tough
you know we're going to be tough you can
also that's not different from what they
should do here exhilaration should have
already here but most of people's
Silicon Valley if they don't know five
people who can give them advice and not
good entrepreneurs anyway I would say
you can call your friends and friends
friend and somebody you know everybody I
know know somebody who's sort of you
know can put them in contact with
somebody so you know so I think that's
kind of the way I would look at it any
him smart thoughtful angels
people can go to open the kimono discuss
that idea ask for honest feedback I
think would be very valuable in
that doesn't exist people come to us
sometime when you say you know look we
can give you advice we can't fund you
right now you know you really need to
polish up your thinking so I would say
it's a chicken-and-egg you may be more
dangers will come around once there are
more successes and so on so I I would
sort of put it that way I would say both
sides like I think both sides are to
blame from what is happening to all your
thoughts on that I think it's you know
it's a little bit of both
you know I mean I'll give you an example
of you know from an investor perspective
you know give you a real case study in
two minutes you know we got interested
some years ago two years ago three years
ago in the travel industry online travel
industry in India really weren't a lot
of players at that time there was only
one company make my trip and we had
looked at you know we have been
investors here in the u.s. in get their
comm you actually got bought very
successful IPO and in an acquisition we
looked at their whole industry and said
well China done very well they had been
a couple of players in China that our
emotions winners and so we stipulated a
couple years three years ago that the
online travel industry in India should
be a real growth opportunity right so
then we one of our partners started
spent a lot of time looking at an
industry we came across two other
companies I won't name any names because
I don't embarrass anyone or any of the
investors the bother we're not here we
miss our company young young graduate
out of Harvard MBA program no it's time
to think that was the process we look at
he looked at the deal and we said no
domain experience you know other than
you know a spreadsheet exercise and
perhaps some analysis of the industry
you have no idea look how the industry
functions so another deal same thing
so we decided on investment either of
those so then we said we'd have to roll
our own so we started look around and
actually found two entrepreneurs in
London that were originally from India
and we're working with an online travel
company in the UK now granted they
didn't quite understand the market
dynamics of India but they understand
they understood totally about the
systems you gotta build and how do you
scale systems and so on and so forth so
we convince these guys to move to India
they were looking to move to India so
you know our paths crossed and we ended
up running the company and you know in
less than two years of operation with a
number two company company called
AFRICOM that came from nowhere okay see
that's where you know domain experience
background and and and you know fair
amount of experience in the industry
really helped out so I think it's an
issue of finding so you know you're
going back you know the you see a lot of
entrepreneurs and that by the way
happens here too right so it's no
different see a lot of entrepreneurs
they don't have the relevant background
they don't have relevant experience it's
very difficult to to say well yes we'll
write a check to you you know unless you
can show us a team and the founders that
have relevant background that's always
you know it's one of the mantras you
know you have to have entrepreneurs that
that have relevant experience now
there's always you know exceptions
Google right gosh you know but you know
for every Google there's thousands of
companies that fail because the
expertise wasn't there to start with
know so you know it's very important so
pain I'd like to go back to the yacht
for example and that would bleed until
you know what but I think I try that be
jumping out of myself but and I also
want to make sure that we give people
here the opportunity of contradicting or
calling you out and what you just said
how it works share is anyone here you
know has anyone here at the experience
of going in front of us looking to start
up business in India where they thought
it was a good idea everything else
worked it would have got funded in the
US but for the way things are in India I
guess it didn't get funded and that's
really my question and and I as maybe
you can help me from the entrepreneurs
perspective if you think that's because
I mean I guess times are different now
but a few years ago you know there were
companies being funded on business plans
and but not necessarily experienced
entrepreneurs in the valley I don't
think I've seen any of those in India
and that's really the heart of
entrepreneurship taking the risk from
the investor side even if it's you know
of a small Shack or Northey bees getting
started you know five thousand or
million dollars do you see that
happening there's a lot of very sharp
highly educated highly skilled engineers
that you know really can build systems
and so on and so forth so when we look
at companies that we see in India the
question you ask is okay help me
understand why the market is right and
and and then the question that comes up
is okay so if you were building the next
generation XYZ right you ask yourself
where are the early adopters of this XY
is the product going to be and if the
early adopters and here's the challenge
right boom right the challenge is that
the early adopters by and large not
always but for some of these products
end up being companies that are going to
be here in the US and Europe
predominantly u.s. right now the problem
that that entrepreneur has right is the
following and that is he's sitting 22
hours away by plane right right and his
early adopters are going to be here in
the US he has no customer intimacy right
and he can't sort of you know walk
across the street every other day or you
know take a ride and say let me tell you
I'm thinking about this feature what do
you think about this let me understand
what you do today
what are your pain points maybe I can
come up with something that reduces
those pain points so depends on what
product and what market
you're serving right now I think that
picture will change right because today
you know the Indian enterprise market
itself if you look at the stock by
enterprise right financial services
companies and industries and so on
enterprise you know you ask yourself why
haven't there been a lot of successful
Indian software companies that are
selling products and licenses there are
companies this iFlex was reasonably
successful Oracle bought it but the
challenge that we run into is a lot of
those entrepreneurs are too far away
from where the markets are and India yet
is not an early adopter of technology
not that will change right and it is
changing and what will happen in India
and is happening in India is something
that happened in the u.s. about 20-30
years ago 20-30 years ago as wages began
to increase right what corporations are
to do was to invest heavily in
technology so that they could still have
productivity gains right wages are going
up I gotta get productivity gains
otherwise my margins are going on the
road right now India's had the same
problem right I mean you hear about
wages escalating and you know they've
slowed down a little bit but you know
they'll they'll pick up again because
they too have a finite supply of
Engineers you know quality engineers and
so on so I think as India over a period
of time as Indian enterprises start to
become early adopters of technology and
they are becoming early adopters of
technology slowly I think there comes a
time I don't know whether it's five
years from now ten years from now but I
can guarantee you that there comes a
time when an engineer sitting in
Bangalore will not have to fly the
United States right we'll take a trip
over to Mumbai right or Bangalore and
say you've got the list and greatest
something and what are your pain points
with this latest and greatest something
and I think I can come up with something
that will give you better whatever
performance price advantage so I think
we'll get there now in certain areas
happening already if you forget the
enterprise for a second if you look at
certain sectors of the wireless industry
right there are certain things that are
happening in India that are head of hair
because for example you know talk about
a low-cost phone
right low-cost cell phone you can never
design that cell phone here in the US
right because the engineers hair even
though they are very sophisticated
they're too far away from where $5 or
$15 cell phone has to work right or has
to be matched at the retailers got a
cell for 15 bucks so you get the iPhones
being made here for you know the market
that's early adopters of high
smartphones but when it comes to
different cell phone that's got a cell
for 15 bucks right which means cost of
goods got to be like 3 or 4 bucks and
never get designed here that has to be
designed there so if someone came to us
here in the valley and seminar design a
$15.00 phone for you
it says you know you ought to be sitting
in Bangalore will move you there will
actually pair you with someone and and
by the same token you know we come
across engineers in the in the in
Bangalore they'll say I got this great
idea of the next generation so
architecture services only or whatever
right what we do then in that case is
say no since your markets are going to
be in the US let me tell you what we
ought to set up a cross-border company
and the cross-border company to us and
these gentlemen to some extent reflect
that as well is it has to be a company
that's got presents hair and presence
there as well you can do all the
development work there but the product
management people that are going to be
interfacing with customers and
interfacing with the early adopters they
ought to be sitting here and let's
collaborate together so you know there's
different models of starting these
companies in fronting these companies
disasters of being where you leave a
bunch of engineers all by themselves
right and they design something they
always design something but the question
is is that what the market needs right
in fact you know I was I mean I did you
not I remember an engine has a very
sharp don't get me wrong I remember
interviewing a VP of engineering for one
of my companies about two years ago and
he wanted to actually meet with me I
wasn't on the board of directors of the
company and you know what questions the
end for me he wanted to know okay what
are your views on product management are
you going to hire a VP of Product
Management into this company and I said
absolutely we don't have one yet but we
we're looking at hiring one so then I
asked him I said why are you concerned
about that and you know this is this is
what this guy told me and I thought it
was fascinating
he says promote as a VP of engineering I
can feel anything
give me enough time and they're not
money I built anything but the big
question is am i building the right
thing does anyone care at the end of the
exercise whether I built it or not right
does it work or not is someone going to
buy it someone will pay for right so I
think that product management issue and
right now there are product management
issues in India right you don't have
enough people there yet enough engineers
that our product management expertise
not me weren't moving back slowly and I
think you're seeing companies here there
are sort of what I call cross-border
companies where you know their markets
might be here India as well here as well
and so you know they've got presence
here as well as back in India so is it
that you see are you seeing that we're
not really likely to see a Facebook
developing in India all because the
usership or something that that is more
in the US and then it spreads outside
but you need to in depends on the
industry right yeah depends on the
industry and the challenge in India
right I mean the number of computers and
access and all that is you get that
started and I think there's another
issue here also I mean this is sort of
more just like there are entrepreneurs
in India who are engineers and haven't
got the access knowledge of the their
market I think the same is true also of
investors and this is not a
generalization but a lot of investors of
enter India in your emulator yeah and
you know the first question is boy you
know this is a strange odd market things
happen very differently here the safe
thing to do is find a company that has
already got customers got revenue and
got some traction better to invest there
than to find a guy who walks in my door
who's an engineer from IIT it says I've
got a brilliant idea because you know
truth be told more than just a brilliant
idea it's and you know engineering
expertise it takes a lot more to build a
company whether in the US or in India so
I think there's some of that you know I
you know I've spoken to a lot of
investors who have sort of a just about
getting the Indian market and I can tell
their safety is boy you know if you've
been in Silicon Valley you've built a
company there and you are now coming
India yes I want to talk
but if you're just walking in from an
IIT come to me later you know after you
got your first customers and so on so I
think in unless you're selling a $15.00
falling yes but even then yeah yeah if
it's for a local market it's a little
easier Facebook but I think even in that
case right if you're if you as an
investor haven't spent enough time in
India you wonder about boy how is this
going to be marketed or who do you need
to work with who or your partner is
going to have to be you need to work
with the government what you know etc
etc so I think there's a little bit of
that fear it's changing because the
knowledge is just like product knowledge
I was amazed at some of the companies in
terms of thanks the web how much
knowledge they have about US markets
because you can find it on the web
you know likewise for investor so I
think it's changing but I think there's
a little bit of a problem both sides
right now which hopefully is going to be
is the question about we can be a
Facebook coming out of India so I think
you have to look at look at is going to
be a company like Skype you know the
Skype started in Estonia wherever you
know people were all over the place and
I think that the model was very
different in the u.s. not as cost
consciousness Indy is or Estonia might
have been it made more sense to start a
company like Skype in because nobody
could pay for phone calls international
calls and so on you solving a problem
you are solving a problem that is
typical for the steps situation but that
can be taken worldwide you know so I
think that's the kind of let's say
mobile more while many money transfer um
or you know payments nobody's going to
start a company in the u.s. to do that I
mean it's too easy to have crazy
everybody has credit cards and so on but
any uh nobody has their cards so maybe
it makes sense to start a company there
it can get a big market share because
people don't have credit cards so me
that's just one example the challenge
would be to grow that and expand that to
the US but any virtual mark here yeah
you don't have a global company coming
out exactly so you know you could
ultimately it could be convenient to be
able to wave your phone and make your
groceries you know payment or know your
Starbucks coffee payment right with
waving at rather than taking the cash
out of your pocket or using your credit
card but it's not going to happen here
if this is too easy to meander too many
credit cards here so I think you think
very differently in India and I do
believe that well Facebook a bad
examples since you know everybody sort
of shooting
than these days but let's say whatever
you know eBay or whatever or Facebook
anyway so I think a company like that
will come out of India but it won't look
anything like this could be very
different it'd be very different company
and promote is funding some of those
companies you know we are finding some
of those companies as well it's going to
be different the big thing in India is
what I say is business model innovation
how do you lose something at a lower
cost and provide better higher-quality
service so I have to summarize that
discussion I guess how many physical sex
when she not not every company that gets
started in India he's going to have a
product or service but that's relevant
here perhaps neither should we you know
you're you don't sit there and say well
you know well you got it it's working in
Indiana we got to go to the US why I
mean the Indian market is large enough
we have a company you know you talk
about Facebook is not a Facebook but
it's somewhat you know in an adjacent
space company called silica right silica
is our online portal you go there it's
very good for yellow pages and
classifieds how India has got a real
problem you know you don't have really
efficient Yellow Pages small businesses
you know don't have yellow pages and so
on as you and I know them here in the US
and so they serve a local need right we
and so that model will never work here
in the US there is no need for that kind
of a model but it's got tremendous need
in India and so you know they focus on
that market and and and so it's like
that $15 cell phone right no need for it
here but cash absolute tremendous need
for so you know so it's a localized
business model that probably applies
only to that part of the world maybe
China and so on but pressures focus I
guess to summarize that discussion I
mean if you're someone's article looking
to start a business in India be careful
of what the market is you know focus on
the more I don't talk about you what's
your service a product right what's your
market right and do you have relevant
expertise both on the product side
management product management marketing
side as well as the engineering side to
be able to go address that market and to
be sure I want to give credit to
investors also you know drive folks like
yourselves who are doing good stuff in
India I mean how calmly is a good
example yachts are is another good
example these are companies that
probably would not have got funded in
the US because you know there is a
dearth you know there is no dearth of
although ad networks or online business
rebels but if you can structure it for
something you know cut and paste what
works you and we're eager to start a
travel company for India based here
right I mean come on but if you
structure it well then that you're more
likely to it and if you have good
quality products or technology and team
then obviously it goes hand-in-hand with
understanding the market but then you're
likely to get you know make it really
successful for the Indian market which
itself is going that could be a good
sound business model it operates
differently in India and promote can
tell you all the differences compared to
the US you can't just copy Expedia move
it to India it's going to be a failure
and I think and I think that is the key
is that you know you I mean for us
investing in India since that's all we
do the model you know you learn from the
US and you learn more what you should
not do from the US rather than learn
what you do from the US you know that's
what the sort of experience tells you is
what you should not be doing and I think
you have to have a model that suited for
India and I think you know if you have
an invested promoter has a good team in
India we have a very good team in India
as well I think unless you have somebody
who lives there and breathe the air and
knows what's going on you know if you're
thinking that you'll fly in there one
day and make an investment this could be
a disaster
I guess go to the energy but to really
fully understand what's going on both
the positives and negatives any other of
risks in all kind of things that you
don't even think about here yeah and we
we should talk about that I mean but I
just want to summarize that a good
analogy might be McDonald's right I mean
obviously my dogs all over but you know
when they were looking to get into India
the better be prepared to have a Nalu
burger on the menu right you have got to
have that otherwise ever and not Leslie
a be further on a low burger but it's
again the model works though monument so
you would get give more British to a
strong flushed out team that's you know
that connects you know beyond and strong
when you put your you guys working
together as you can build here you can
get people on stock options and get them
see the challenge is you know if you if
you do a start-up you don't have to deal
it doesn't run so so therefore you know
it gets back to who are you funny right
and do you have a common vision right
does the entrepreneur understand that G
over a pair of time is going to have to
add team members frankly is no different
than they know it's over here
I mean when we start companies err you
don't have a total team right you might
have two guys you might have an
engineering person and you might have
some marketing skills on the team but
putting myself yeah yeah by team by
definition is not complete two or three
guys in a garage and so but you have to
at least you know get a sense for is
there some common thinking here right
commonality in thinking is is the
entrepreneur coachable right it's no
different here than there right is this
someone that's going to listen right and
those are those are reference checks
those are judgment calls on interaction
or the person to see is this a coachable
person or is this a stubborn person
right will he ever take advice from his
board let me use that to I guess the
point earlier to leading to another
discussion may be jumping ahead but what
are the exit opportunities available in
India especially you know public capital
markets are probably fairly strong now
robust especially if you compare them to
what's happening in the US but what
about M&A and one of the challenges I
hear about you don't have there's many
big players that are out there the
Cisco's the Oracles the eBay is that
you're always looking for positions we
have the Reliance's that are I don't
know what they have whether they're
looking back to is they're probably
looking to steal the intellectual
property not necessarily liens as such
but the big players so you wanna be
careful and the opportunity isn't as
high in India for existing companies or
developed trading their face of existing
companies I think it's true how do you
overcome that challenge and then you
know is that something that you how much
create is that there isn't that
investment philosophy and how do you see
that changing well that you know so I
mean that goes back to you know you have
to execute you have to get bigger right
I mean there are companies that don't
execute you know they get acquired but
those are fireside sales right no one
makes any money and yes you're right I
think by and large you know there's less
mas that take place within the country
that then you would see out here in a
market that's a little bit more
efficient does how would you grow your
company in India are given those
challenges and especially if you know if
you're a mobile company for example and
you are reliant on the big telcos
the reliance is the Airtel's they not
gonna play bollocks but then I will be
doing strategic partnerships or you know
channel distributions for you where they
don't make nor large portion of what you
know about the bike
I think IPOs in India the market is
better but the criteria is is is just as
higher possibly higher meaning if to get
to a tremendous size and scale and
profitability and so on so forth so
that's possible but you know I think you
can't go into the zooming that's that's
the only option I think the other
interesting option you know for a
company like us and certainly others
could be as India continues to grow and
progress as a market a lot of US and
European companies want a presence in
India so let's say with its search or
video or its whatever business it is if
you want to enter the Indian market and
you aren't already there because the
markets already evolved what's the next
best thing
acquire a company that's got a good
footprint there so I think the
acquisitions aren't necessarily Indian
companies buying these startups I think
it's American European other companies
that want to be in the market so I think
we'll we'll see a lot of that you know
right now until value your local for
exactly because entering a company in
India requires so much local expertise
talent and so and so forth that if you
said I mean think of Starbucks right I'm
tried to enter India and boy you know
they backed up pretty quickly we
realized a very different environment be
there was already some players in there
there's going to be several of those and
then the next thing is well it's a
growing market we need a play there
what's the next best thing to do buy
your way into it and that's I think a
good exit for for us and for you
they're one of also get the benefit of
you know for the academic minded people
here on legal and you know regulatory
framework if you could please compare
the structure typical structure of an
investment into an Indian portfolio
company with a typical structure for
Delaware company what rights I mean if
someone was looking to invest in Indian
company or someone was looking to set up
an Indian company that will need
investment from a u.s. investor what are
the typical rights that you would get in
India that you would not necessary care
in the US and vice versa you know what
what are the ones that you would get in
the US that you would not expect because
of the existing framework in in Indian
companies and how I had any challenges
in structuring those investments or such
well I mean there are some challenges in
Indian companies but we try to make our
agreements as similar to the US
investment as possible you know in India
has different regulations about
preferred stock and in companies and so
on and rather than going into the
details of that but you know we work
with those regulations and still get to
essentially not quite but essentially
the same same resolve on view is that
anything that has been proven in the
u.s. worked for 25 years does need to be
change in India don't change it I mean
it will get full of the companies like
whatever it is put them into the
companies act and make them work I mean
there's plenty of other places to
innovate why bother
on paper here on paper leave it for the
dumb lawyers to you well you know I
think the kind of other other issues to
deal with so I I would I can we just try
to make it as much as possible
sometime when you have a you have big
corporate investors in a company there
can be a little bit of a problem with
that there's some kind of a laws about
26 percent ownership and if you're not
going into that certain industries
certain industries limit certain
industries in so media telecom and so on
you know you you cannot
has to be 26 percent ownership by by the
local authorities in some case you know
like 51
some cases more like 50 my leg insurance
and you know I mean some time here to go
be here to go for a couple of our
investors to God please to finance and
it's a nightmare but that would be it is
to take time to get it done I think a
more relevant thing for people wanting
to immerse there is the whole issue of
double taxation that's right so
therefore you know a lot of our all our
investments we will go through a
Mauritius or a Cayman Island entity
because of tax treaties that exists
between came in and Mauritius and India
all ideas you know you don't want to
take pay tax twice you know want to sell
your investment then pay taxes in India
and also pay taxes here so so there are
some tax issues and so on and I can
quickly state or that the India
Mauritius tax treaty what is look at you
know the jurisdiction of the investor
and if you set up a malicious entity
then it's malicious entity that pays tax
is according to the laws of malicious
and capital gains and module for example
is zero so you avoid having to pay tax
just to summarize what's the typical
size of investment in India and and I
guess we're back to what you were
signaling the emotional each bout you
know having the time in years that
founders are putting in what should they
expect you know what percentage of the
company they should expect for CDJ fine
you know I would say India is a market
great there is nothing like a typical
CDs a I mean I think because none of the
people in India start companies with
their own money or their parents funding
and so on because of getting things
going in India at a very early stage can
be very low but you know so so I think I
I would say that our Series A
investments very for a very wide range
from a million dollars to ten million
dollars and it depends on on what the
company needs
what does need to do to operate in the
next 12 18 24 months whatever I say but
it really makes sense and so on I mean
we really focus on of course returns for
ourselves but also having a significant
ownership for the entrepreneurs because
we we believe that's good for us
obviously you get entrepreneurs a big
ownership and sometimes
lazy too much money can be detrimental
to the entrepreneur so you want to raise
the right amount of money it there is a
bigger variation than my
being in the US but I think the u.s. is
also getting well maybe we are no we are
we are like the u.s. used to be like
I saw investments or less than a million
dollars that time we'll see again as
much as twenty million dollars I think I
think I would call typicall typicall
maybe you know it all over because you
know what you find also as you know it's
not just the issue of Series A because
you find you know sometimes it's a start
up so start up in the CDJ is not a large
mark right and then you might find a
company that's been around for two or
three years right and has been
bootstrapped and has got revenue and so
on so a series a investment invest in
that company is a different company
it's a different valuable that's not
different from what you what you see
here is very inside you know the dollar
you can stretch more yeah yes number did
support them yeah
but one thing I would say though is you
know it's very interesting I think the
Indian entrepreneur is very cash
conscious because they have had to for a
very very long period of time survive
with very little outside capital so you
know it's just amazing how effectively
they are able to stretch the dollar or
or the rupee you know cap capital
outside capital that they get just
amazing I can stop talk about controls
then how likely are they to know to to
be excited about giving up control of a
family than sort of a venture related to
you know thinking that you know they
probably need less money because they
can stretch it more they by giving up
less of their company and retaining
control and how important is it for you
to have significant amount of opera not
necessary or pressure on buts only
decision-making control and any
interesting in sensitive where you know
that's clasped and because of more
comfortable there's always you know
there's always clashes everywhere right
but specifically are because out here
any nature not really know it's the same
because you know a lot of companies will
be funded right are not family-owned
businesses necessarily right now they
might have been some family money but
some of these businesses are no
different than what you see here right
two or three entrepreneurs get together
you know there might be friends there
might be business associates from the
past and
you know we just funded a company which
is a group of people that came out of
emphasis in fact the finical guys right
that the Betty and all this gay party no
there's no Betty and Rhonda and so on so
you know these are not family now they
had their own money in there
perhaps early for two years three years
they put their own money right but they
knew that you know they had a capital
structure where they could see they can
understand what do you exactly and
dilution and you know and then even
though you know we might not have
majority control in the business you
know in terms of ownership you know as
you've seen agreements and all you can
you know get feet or rights and all
country you know certain matters right
there are genuine right where you really
need to have a common understanding
right in a unified understanding so you
can't do that position unless everyone
agrees you can't take on debt unless
everyone agrees you know which is no
different than kinds of governance you
would have here in CDs idiots
so I guess that leads me to the question
but you maybe you answered that already
another now there now there are some
family of what is mrs. right and and you
know some of the later stage deals that
we see our family-owned businesses right
and it's a nightmare dealing with those
do you name names or now again
how about absolutely I think the leaders
family one business no different than
family-owned businesses there yeah right
I mean go talk to TA and spectrum and so
on the do investments in later stage
companies here in the US that have been
bootstrap right and you're the first
money going into a company that's 50 60
million in revenue and the founder of 99
percent right well you know same issues
so they give you wear the same hat yeah
so against I mean as I say you may have
answered this question already but
enough to get others also what are
things that entrepreneurs in India can
learn from their counterparts here and
some I suppose vice versa in terms of
innovation
things of all are there any things that
other need similarities or differences
that you don't draw from I would say the
Indian entrepreneurs the good thing
about the u.s. is people think big and I
think the US Indian entrepreneurs
sometimes don't think we're big enough
you know you got a you got to start from
a big thinking I know reality may be a
little different and you've got a sort
of moderate you're thinking based on
that but Indian entrepreneurs generally
they could people composing the plan
will I have tell me the nods in revenue
in six years I mean what do we do with
that company it doesn't make sense for
us it's a great family business you
produce cash flow you can live happily
ever a life service like sighs nothing
so you know I think I think in India
just people don't think think big enough
you know that's second thing I would say
is that team building is so critical and
I don't think the Indian entrepreneurs
oftentime understand the importance of
team building you know it is just so
critical to bring in the best people in
the company give them whatever
reasonably you have to give them and so
on I think the u.s. we focus on that we
know we think that's really critical so
I do a few things many things you know
that you can you can any other youth the
US entrepreneurs also have a sense of
urgency that is sometime not there in
India but that's a culture which I go
but you know we just got to change that
this is not gonna work so I think I
think a few things about is you want to
add one thing going the other way which
I feel that Indian entrepreneurs do
really well and you know know in you and
promote have met many many more than I
have but they they exist in thrive in an
environment where there is no
reliability on that in the
infrastructure and is infrastructure I
mean you know you're building a company
based on services that you get from
other people other agencies and you
managed to miss getting a permit from
the government it could take one month
it could take a year and you have to run
a company and avoid the pitfalls of
these kinds of things you're going for a
meeting
it could take one hour it could take
half a day and and so you you manage to
work through these kinds of situations
it
requires a real tolerance for you know
otherwise your you know your head will
explode if you not use this stuff your
centre phone : if you think that can
promote talk about capital efficiency I
think the US entrepreneurs by allies
don't understand capital efficiency you
know how important and how well they can
manage waste less money I think I would
call it being more adaptive you know I
think in your enterpreneurs are not more
adapted in the US entrepreneurs you know
here you get it by something with the
fall apart you in the enterpreneur they
don't care they disasters happen every
day just as long as they don't get it
they don't report him and you know
here's the right back you know you I
mean he knows that because you know
you've been involved with per system a
little bit you know we have an
investment in a company called
persistent systems I mean it's a company
this outsourced product well they took
million dollars of outside capital
initially and they put strapped on a
million dollars right we got in the
company is already thirty five million
in revenue so we put some money and they
won't they didn't need the money right
the only reason they said it will take
money because we want your help
right so we'll take money but I mean
that's a somewhat of a family owned
business right father and son very
closely son but we know father influence
and so on million dollars yeah very hard
to find those kinds of businesses right
you try to do those businesses here
today yes you know before you know it
well you know I need 35 million bucks to
get to cash flow breakeven and then the
35 ends up being seventy fresh and some
respects that was a groundbreaking top
investment so yeah so I know I was at
coulee you know helping you guys set up
the militia so it was the first
malicious investment for you guys for
you oh yeah and yeah and there was sense
that you know this was and it obviously
led to really good things about know
that you're actually working all of that
as well let me jump on the scumbag
within their type of no scenario where
they playing down here
knows about it so I guess you mentioned
about you know being able to stretch and
being innovative our new Orden respects
that are different in you know obviously
a lot of people here understand that
with the some within a psycho
description let me lead that then this
my last question are open up to know any
other questions but then in you
mentioned not chat earlier you know
there are thus delight of sunlight I
think company that you talked about are
there opportunities for investors here
or even entrepreneurs to look at those
below middle class everyone talks about
India's middle class but just below
middle class kind of you know
opportunities of this teaming no need
then for growth and they have different
needs you know it's not necessarily the
internet but the basic lighting system
yeah so you speak to so yeah 3d design
caching it's started by two GSP
graduates yes and Goldman and you
probably know them better than you know
we do then you know what they had never
lived in India they got Grady I start
this company and I think in every way
they have really innovated the product
is a is inexpensive lighting for rural
use solar power it can also be charged
and so on and I think the whole thing
that that you know is there you can get
a tremendous market the you know that
the villages and small towns in India
are the richer than they used haven't
ever ever before you know some of the
small towns are actually you know richer
than big cities like Delhi and Bombay so
but I think when you come up with the
products like that they really have to
put the alien Indian environment this
thing has to be low no cost obviously it
has to be completely sealed a lot of
dust in small villages you know this
light is completely seen would make
sense for the US and most importantly is
you've got to figure out how to use the
existing infrastructure or whatever
there is because this kind of a product
cost of distribution can kill you and
this company the cost of distribution
which is less than 10% of the price of
the product and what they are doing is
basically using existing channels you
know they have a partnership with minder
and member which is the biggest tractor
manufacturer real here they have shops
in every village or every you know town
and so on and so basically it gives the
farmers a reason to come to the shop and
they hopefully end up getting X
200 products and so on so after the
generating our infrastructure and trying
to reach each individual con right you
can't really do that you can't scale
faster the company harvest is being very
well I'm saying you know it's not an
easy as business but the opportunities
are tremendous and it's a business has
to be infrastructure be hard to
replicate
but once you've signed up with my mentor
and somebody has conned into the same
thing with them so I will do others have
thoughts about your dough side up sort
of opportunities below the surface not
the Internet the exciting stuff that be
aware of in India opportunities there as
you know and promote for example somes
would you find something like that and
iist would you start something about the
afternoon yeah I think they're
absolutely there are those opportunities
at the grassroots level if you can
figure out distribution which is the
biggest challenging I heard of the ideas
or companies doing things like clean
water you know in villages you have a
low unit there 50 PI say or whatever
people come and put some money they need
clean water I mean it's easy to build
these systems the question is how do you
get the route they're already collecting
money how do you know right all that and
a lot of Indian business like land are
being Wanda's banks and others that have
set up some basic infrastructure there
the extent you can tap into that and
solve the distribution problem I think
there's plenty of opportunity and I
agree it's a it's a it's a land of
masses in everything we talk about you
know 180 million cell phones are you
know everything just scales very very
quickly if it catches on you got to be
settings in million phones or 15 miles
of the edge yeah under the transactions
you know 70 Plus 70% of the Indian
population lives in small villages right
so it's here 3 3 or 4 th how easy to
find the partners the channel partners
or Depot's and the wind's rose
you know here to be innovative in every
you know in this company minders
actually have a small investment and you
know we did that you brought the men
just for that reason you know with that
and you know we told them that a fluster
reason we want you as an investor are
usually comfortable you know considering
that and so on I think you've got to
make it profitable for where your
partner is
it's nothing is easy but you know if
your partner is going to make money from
it you know it's going to get business
fondue better sure people will sign up
in a in a heartbeat actually you know
that itself I've heard of I don't know
if the company just yet but I've heard
of business plans which are where you're
supposed to where they want to set up a
rural distribution network because you
know they expect that order that will
get done yes I mean I so you know before
I join in phasis I worked for five years
with in the Sun lever which is the
largest consumer products company and
the rural distribution is is it almost I
mean that that's what you know marketing
and rural distribution decides your your
success or failure in the markets and
pricing for that's another thing which
is extremely important you have to
attractive yeah I say you know you dad
we I was in the packaged tea division
and whenever we added a product that was
smaller and lower priced then what we
have so we had you know fifty grams we
introduced 50 grams 50 grams would be
double the volume of hundred grams then
we'd introduce 25 grams there we double
the volume of 25 gram so the and this is
all where the price per kilo is higher
and the margin per kilo is higher for
the company so you can imagine what the
unit price is doing there it's the
companies making more money and so so
it's a it's a very very interesting
place the whole rural distribution I
think if that's that's that it's self
distribution infrastructure is a good
startup idea and I don't want to sound
so much as a like a B C but you know you
have to know your market and really
believe in that market really and I can
give an example I mean X GSB students
know I just I worked with him two years
ago and the team came came together and
they were thinking of doing you know
these movie theaters no chain of movie
theaters across India and I thought it
all now you know this is curvier if it's
not the best place to be doing it we
have established players and what they
were doing is you're partnering with the
Mexican company make it even more
expensive but you know really good
service all of that so it's not for me
to know what the Nexus the investors to
say you know tell you whether it's a
good idea or not you should have done
your homework and come back with a
passion and really you know as
entrepreneurs here if the investors
don't do it you know it's their problem
not yours and you still go forward for
it and you create that one in these guys
two years down vacillation a million
dollars are going to gangbusters and
developing yeah I think one thing I
would add is you know there are a lot of
opportunities but you definitely don't
want to be sitting here in Silicon
Valley dreaming them up but anyway to
get out there because almost every
business I mean your example that you
know we all understand if you look at
the Starbucks Coffee Day example right
there are nuances for example when I
first walked your coffee day I went and
stood at the counter and every is
looking at me strangely what are you
doing there you supposed to sit down
they come and serve you all right well
that's how it works in India you don't
go stand in line the counter I think I
don't think Starbucks got that I don't
know if this is a fact but I'm just
thinking out loud if you enter the
market thinking way to replicate
something here so I think you really
have to be the wheat ended up you know
innovating our business in India
substantially and even today is
different from how we do it here but it
was just trying to figure out what works
there how what your pricing model needs
to be how you distribute the product
it's very different I think my base
advice is don't don't call the business
plan can't read in topical matter it's
not books not